dans un désert impitoyable où règne la
terreur c'est tout moche et pas fini
mais c'est pas votre faute vous aime
bien quand même
le courage de deux petits et mignons
animaux je ne suis pas petit et on n'est
pas mignon va changer leur destin à
jamais je fais partir et genre tu vas
aller où
juste vivre dans l'oasis non tu
plaisantes qu'un non seulement on peut
pas y rentrer et on peut pas s'en tirer
mais non il présente pas grand mystère
l'oasis à partie en serpent vert mais
c'est ici que tous nos ennuis ont
commencé
s'il te plaît me dit rien
il faut sortir d'ici ils vont tuer
sortir le temps je m'appelle et 20
montez aja hockey aja j'aimerais aller
plus loin découvrir ce qui se cache
derrière ces rochers
un moment intime et par de la liberté
eva
on doit sauver ma part
un seul d'entre eux peu sur vire
on est tout seul espoir tu le reconnais
mais les gars si on parle bien de ma
soeur laisser tomber et intelligente
sérieusement
ces pc c'était plus fort que moi tu es
tellement courage
jeux super entraînés au cou alors si je
m'énerve ça peut très vite dégénérer
ne riez pas croiser comme une caravane
caravane de trois hommes et un enfant en
direction de sotchi ville avec des
dromadaires dans l'un portait deux
paniers de panthère jolie serpent vert
qui cherchent à s'échapper
oui oui oui c'est ça les rend samedi
rien du tout aventure marrant des
paysages touchant du désert hervé
d'amour
[Musique]
dans le point
ce que
je joue le personnage de pitt qui est un
petit scorpion fragile mais rigolo
mon rôle dans sa race et le rôle d'un
serpent vert qui s'appelle evard c'est
une jeune fille qui vient d'une famille
plutôt riche et ce qu'elle aimerait
faire si s'enfuir et c'est un peu
compliqué pour elle elle va vraiment
souffrir et elle va rencontrer une
personne en particulier et c'est comme
ça qu'ils restent construire sont en
hausse à hajar est un cobra un jeune
cobra qui n'a pas encore mué avec son
copain pitt cd sableux donc eux ils
vivent du côté des déserts du désert et
un jour il arrive à rentrer dans l'oasis
et c'est là que l' aventure commence mon
personnage dans sahara est un danseur
serpent qui s'appelle georges qui aime
beaucoup ce qu'il est je crois qu'il n'a
pas de prénom
on l'appelle le poisson des sables et il
est complètement taré complètement
bizarre complètement étrange
j'interprète gary un jeune serpents
vivants parmi la tribu des serpents vert
c'est le fils du roi
donc il a la belle vie quoi il n'a pas
trop d'avenir mais
[Musique]
parce que tu trouve qu'ici on est bien
regarde moi on est des lozère non non et
douceurs sont émus que nous comment
est-ce qu'on juin cobras alors là c'est
comme pour les autres doublage en fait
on n'est pas trop un serpent ce qui est
bien aussi dans sa race et des serpents
mais ils n'ont pas beaucoup de choses à
par l'apparence de serre prendre déjà
ils n'ont pas la langue fourchue
il rend pas ils sont un peu comme des
centaures ils ont toujours une posture
un peu droit comme les humains en fait
ils sont toujours un peu en hauteur donc
ils sont pas du tout comme ça rampant et
et donc ils ont un côté très humain et
je pense qu'en plus on est là pour ça
nous apporter l'humanité à ce serpent
donc en fait on n'a pas du tout âge ou
un serpent et va cesser c'est une jeune
fille elle est certes sous la forme d'un
serpent mais en fait c'est une jeune
femme c'est une adolescente qui était en
train de devenir une femme à vrai dire
et c'est le le rôle d'une fille de mon
âge approximativement donc donc on joue
juste quelqu'un en fait tu me dégoûtes
j'en veux plus de vivre ici tu me rend
malade tu m'étouffe tu comprends c'est
toujours la même chose avec le doublage
clc c'est un plaisir pour la créativité
pour l'imagination donc on regarde les
images on essaye de s'imaginer quel type
de voix peut avoir un personnage aussi
burlesque et puis on s'amuse par rapport
à un film on n'a pas besoin de pareille
comme ça si je me mets appareils comme
ça dans un film à faire des dons il en
fait des caisses non
pour le coup c'est vraiment une première
fois donc vraiment je me suis laissé
faire je vais manger j'ai écouté le
metteur en scène
je suppose qu'on essaie d'être à la fois
vraisemblable
sincère on va dire mais avec un espèce
d'accent le cartoon avec toujours une
espèce d envie de faire rire être sortir
un peu du réel ça demande beaucoup de
modulation g sentiment qu'il faut être à
la fois juste et et être un peu un peu
oui cartonnesque tout va bien se passer
et tu verras georges la major le georges
mois à la il faut en faire vraiment des
caisses en fait c'est à dire qu'on est
là et il faudra tout donner quoi sert
que je pense que si je faisais si jouer
de la même façon que je joue
actuellement la pour doubler garé dans
un vrai film
je pense que concrètement je me ferais
venir est quoi
c'est un exercice qui est très différent
du naturel habituel mais qui rend bien
en dessin animé
dès les premières secondes quand j'ai
posé ma voix sur le personnage et qu'on
fait une écoute et qu'on voit donc sa
voix sur un personnage d'animation
ça fait un truc quoi c'est un rêve de
gosse de faire de l'animation moi c'est
la première fois que j'en fais je suis
très fier d'être dans celui là parce que
le casting est incroyable et donc le
sahara c'est un terrain de jeu
magnifique pour un film d'animation je
suis très étonné que personne n'y avait
pensé avant
donc je suis très fier d'eux dans le
premier film d'animation qui se passe
dans sa serpent vers nous ok si pas
notre place là bas
c'est intéressant j'avais déjà beaucoup
aimé la première fois hélas depuis ce
matin je m'amuse je m'éclate et chaud ça
vraiment génial c'est une comédie vos
petits et grands dont c'est très amusant
à faire et je pense à regarder aussi
dense et vachement bien là en fait c'est
un espèce de plaisir à retardement parce
qu'on sait que c'est un truc est en
train de se faire avec tout le monde
donc ce qu'on attend tous est le produit
fini mais on sait qu'on a eu ni nos
forces chacun donc ça va être assez
enthousiasmant de voir jay a maintenant
de découvrir ce film me voir ce que
chacun des acteurs en affaires et c'est
là qu'on va aussi découvrir le sar je
crois que tu as vu un bébé vient de
naître attendait qu'est ce qui va se
passer cette année là ça fait plaisir
c'est parti
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est un plus
fort que moi tu es tellement courage jeu
super entraînés en courbe ou alors si je
m'énerve ça peut très vite généreux
[Musique]